jp morgan back super soccer league with
4.8 billion dollars a story from
bloomberg
so chase is bankrolling the biggest
upheaval of european soccer since the
1950s
with the 4.8 bet that has already drawn
heavy criticism from fans domestic
leagues and colleagues and politicians
it will be chaired by board of members
of the founding clubs who on monday
stepped down from the positions in
traditional football associations
uefa and fifa have said that players who
take part in super league may be
excluded from tournaments associated
with traditional football institutions
and national teams by the way that'll
never happen ac milan
inter milan juventus arsenal chelsea
liverpool manchester city manchester
united all these barcelona real madrid
uh atletico it's pretty much the main
ones right
announced the creation of the european
super soccer league on sunday the move
would free uh the clubs
from games against smaller teams that
bring in lower income and would award
some of them permanent memberships
breaking a principle of international
soccer that anyone can qualify
or fail to qualify for the most
prestigious competitions
the approach has parallels with the us
where participation in the most
lucrative
basketball baseball and american
football association participation in
the most lucra uh uh competitors is
guaranteed for clubs
that are already members what are your
thoughts well
i i didn't have very strong feelings on
this i'm not i'm not a soccer fan so
what would i ask myself what would john
stossel do
so when i went out and i did some
research and i interviewed
the biggest soccer fan i know and you
know this guy very well
and he's british and his name is styx
and he's a black englishman and his very
strong feelings on soccer
and i said sticks tell me about this
it's so i'll tell you all about this
and he says they're still in the game
these damn yankees
they're still in the game football is
our heritage and our legacy
and uh it's our lifeblood and we'll
defend it and we'll defend our teams to
the death i mean he was super
sure damn very bad we don't need these
damn yanks
coming over here telling us how to run
our sport it ain't gonna happen and he
was
passionate as hell and i said okay
there's my clip right there so i went
and i found someone who actually
cares about this uh gaf give af
about this and and i i said you win
buddy
and that was the only uh market research
i did and i spoke to stixx
and i'm sure if he ever sees this clip
he'll be happy but anyway that's a shout
out to stixx and john stossel at the
same time
john any strong opinions on this
no but you look at what
bellator and the ufc compete it's good
to have
competition and let things shift around
and it
probably will be good for some of the
players do you follow
soccer at all at all at all
kyle do you have an opinion on this
anything you know
anything sam are you following anything
with the soccer deal
nothing do you have anything on it guys
from norway sam's from columbia you guys
are international soccer what's up
from what i've seen uh essentially this
would open by the way if you're watching
this comment below i'm actually wanting
to hear your thoughts is that a good
idea or bad idea good idea
uh uh just tell us in the comment
section if it's a good or bad idea go
ahead uh this league from what i
understand would open up
to allow uh the teams play against it's
the best of the best it's like this yeah
it's like the all-star league for soccer
and and the way it is the only time they
played against each other is in like
these big leagues like champions league
and sure
yeah at that point it's tournament so
it's it's you're in brackets and you go
forth
so you could have teams that never play
each other because they're
it's it's all in the finals so this way
it would allow
a barcelona regularly to play in
liverpool which are like the two
bigger teams in different countries
which from a
uh the standpoint of a viewer would
allow you to see
these once-in-a-lifetime games that
would happen
yeah regularly so they're modeling
essentially the way a lot of it is done
here in the us
and how the league is structured to try
to do that in europe now obviously i can
also see why
the the leagues in europe would want to
would want to not be a fan of this
because that would pull away from them
um however like you're saying if they're
saying oh you wouldn't be allowed to
play if you did
if barcelona real madrid and atletico
madrid which are the three biggest teams
in spain
all said hey we're joining this they're
not going to not let them play in la
liga they would crush them
no no there's no way in the world that
threat's going to work you can't make a
threat like that and not hold it you're
not going to hold that threat yeah
i know you're a big baseball fan and you
are a big soccer fan i believe
i am so i remember maybe a decade or so
ago
you know national league only played
national league american lead and they
said oh let's play some
inner league games the yankees are going
to play them this is different what
i know what you're saying i basically
want to tee it up for you to see what's
the difference
yeah this this is more college football
sec you know
every you know the best of the best from
every just pretty much come together and
they face out yes
it's what we have right now right but
but it wouldn't be
that the conferences you're playing up
against each other so
so look it it hurts who like 10 year 12
years ago i'm in
2008 i'm in spain barcelona and we're
like what do we do tonight
i go to the concierge at arts hotel what
do you think we should do tonight
there's a big match going on tonight
what's the match
espanol playing barcelona really
messy's playing messi's playing let's go
to the game we went to the game
place is packed jam-packed and they're
playing in the espanol
uh stadium right and there's few
barcelona guys one of our guys is
wearing a
barcelona jersey they surrounded him
they took his jersey off not to take it
off they took it off of them
they said you can't get in with that
okay you don't know this guy guy named
sean they took his jersey up take your
jersey off he takes his jersey out
and he says wear it upside down so it's
the white side we don't even want to see
that color here what
so we want to understand one of our guys
was a soccer guy he got punched in the
face i got into a fight with three guys
at that
jennifer was there took us three hours
to come on it was all over espn
sports center that's what's happening
jennifer will tell you the story on what
happened that day she was frightened
literally we ran to our hotel for three
hours
because it was that insane of what
happened that night with cops chasing
yeah terrible situation but you know
what it was
guess who lost just take a while guess
who lost
espanol lost because messi would run the
speed messi was running is like a car
going
120 miles an hour while the other cars
are going 42 miles an hour just it made
no sense he was like going zigzag
playing high schoolers is what it looked
like right but for espanol
every once in a while they get a chance
to watch messi play against them and
they bash them and they trash them so
to the smaller like you're out of
milwaukee you're going to lose giannis
yesterday they interviewed zion
williamson hey zion
how does it feel playing in new york he
says he have to tell you i played in
madison square garden before when i was
in college and
and man it was amazing and and and and i
just have to be honest with you it's
it's my second favorite place to play
of course i like playing in new orleans
but it's my second favorite center
it's my second favorite place now he's
from new orleans so he wanted to play
he's like a lebron coming from cleveland
so
so he wants to be that guy he's from new
orleans he wanted to play for them so
it's kind of like one of those things
but
you know what happened yesterday what do
you think zion's going to end up in the
next five years
he's going to be an uh knickerbocker in
the next five oh my gosh
so the smaller markets take hits in us
with the way but the draft protects them
lately they've not been protecting them
if harden wants to say he wants to leave
or fade davis wants to say i want to
leave
to go to an la they can do it because
lebron is running the league
player lebron's got the monopoly in the
league today everybody's scared of
lebron
so he dictates where people go to i
think there is
for the fans who want to see the best of
the best
face each other the fans worldwide win
but the local fans lose so you and i may
not give a [ __ ] and say dude who cares
let them play ball dude you're not the
city
where the religion to that's like
telling green bay packers
we're moving the packers and there's not
going to be anything going on over there
because who the hell wants to go to
green bay to watch a game
the local people are like are you i
don't go to church
i skip church and i go to a packer game
are you out of your mind to take this
away
but to you and i were like what is what
is the matter with this guy you okay
you're all right buddy you know so there
is a religion component to soccer and
they're messing with the religion
soccer is a religion two true believer
fans and they're kind of screwing it up
so you got to both arguments make sense
but
this is not going to be pretty if they
continue with this it's going to be a
big fall enough for those local markets
and the local markets generate a lot of
income
of the bigger markets coming to them
they rely like dubrovnik croatia you
ever been there you know how they make
money tourism
there's no other reason to go to
dubrovnik croatia except for wine and
tourism
it's the only reason you go there right
so you're going to take that away
they're going to take a hit so that's my
thoughts so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye